rubble wilson and girlfriend ramona
agroma's fairytale romance continues
with a magical getaway to turkey it's
amazing
and we're getting to live vicariously
through it all with snapshots like this
one rebel luxuriating in a jacuzzi
covered in bubbles and check out this
shot of the two standing on a rock
exploring the gorgeous scenery ramona
also posted this pic she's standing in a
robe at the edge of a beautiful outdoor
pool with an even more beautiful view
calling it all magical in the caption
here's rebel at the same pool wearing
the same robe as hundreds of hot air
balloons float up in the morning sky
behind her rebel had to lose some sleep
to get that gram waking up at five in
the morning for the kodak moment but as
she put it in her caption it was totally
worth it it's like love is in the air in
the air and abroad rebel and ramona's
romance is on a bit of a european tour
before turkey the pair hit up italy they
both shared this pick a look at their
date night in sardinia dressed to the
nines and holding hands rubble rocked a
long yellow dress while ramona opted for
a black blazer and matching pants and we
have to call out those smiles yeah both
ladies were grinning from ear to ear
it's cold if all these sweet social
media moments are any indication things
are going pretty well for ramona and
rebel since they revealed their
relationship they went public earlier
this month after an australian newspaper
attempted to out the pitch perfect
actress revel took control of the story
though breaking the news herself on
instagram by sharing this pic with
ramona and captioning it i thought i was
searching for a disney prince but maybe
what i really needed all this time was a
disney princess a source told e.t at the
time rebel and ramona are very happy
together adding quote their friends are
so supportive of their relationship and
thrilled for them and we know rebel is
all about being her best self these days
telling e.t last month how she's doing
just that my best self is like
definitely someone who's living a
healthy lifestyle
which is both like physically and
mentally and so i'm always kind of
working to to improve things
there and then
um
like working hard but playing hard as
well
[Music]
you